un poisson d'avril plus c'est gros plus
on y croit la télé ne se prive pas de
voir les choses en grand pour ses
blagues en très grand au comme la tour
eiffel
alors est-ce près cette grande nouvelle
nous allons déplacer la tour eiffel
louis hayes compte faire un stade
municipal d'environ cent mille personnes
jusqu'à leur emplacement si je comprends
bien voir grand mais aussi faire preuve
de sérieux le ton presque sévère comme
dans ce jt de 20 heures ou léon zitrone
nous fait état d'une disparition
inquiétante
monsieur giscard d'estaing a perdu le
chien labrador dans l'est fait cadeau la
reine d'angleterre
il s'appelle sandringham il a été perdu
hier après midi du côté du bois de
boulogne
le chef de l'état est très attaché à
l'animal et ils promettent une bonne
récompense à celui qui l'aidera leur
trouver une bonne blague ce peut être
aussi un peu d'installations un nouveau
téléphone installé dans une rame de
métro en 1966 et des complices très
convaincant alors
cette fois monféry mais tout est fluide
en retard parce que ma voiture est en
panne alors j'ai pris le métro étude est
ce qu'il ya dans le métro maintenant et
bien le téléphone c'est formidable de
gentils farce bien vite démenties
mais parfois loin de s'en douter les
journalistes ont vu leurs blagues
devenir réalité
ou presque le 1er avril 1967 le jt de la
rtbf nous explique qu'à paris la voiture
sera interdite au profit de la
bicyclette
si vous êtes contre ce projet absolument
c'est un retour pour moi de 50 ans en
arrière
comprenez la bicyclette c'est fini c'est
fini des voies interdites aux voitures
c'est aujourd'hui le cas dans la
capitale où plus édifiant encore le gac
de 1972 prédit sans le vouloir
l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux
publics
la boutade est devenu réalité 35 ans
plus tard le 1er février 2007
[Musique]